tous les mardis depuis deux mois
ces élèves vont te rendez vous spécial
après l'école on va mettre une partie
supplémentaire au css du site pocketnow
6 en version mobile
ils ont conçu un jeu vidéo et
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière étape
là ils allaient tomber son mobile
j'étais curieux juste savons comment ça
marche et l'application et comment on
fait la programmation et les design
c'est une couleur ça c'était comme toute
chose qu'ils devaient chacun crie un
avatar personnage est le fait des vignes
reste de la classe qui était le
personnage qu'ils avaient illustré ce
truc c g des créations personnelles
donc ouais je trouve ça vraiment cool
comme expérience
si la rencontre entre des jeunes qu'on
veut encourager à persévérer et d'autres
qui travaillent dans le milieu très
branché des nouvelles technologies si ce
manque et que je me vois bien de
l'avenir
c'est dans ce genre de monde que je ne
verrais bien travailler me lever chaque
matin mais je travaille pour être
informaticien logiciel est là comme ça
c'est sur les logiciels et tous
sans rapport important mais ça
m'intéresse aux et des as qui offre des
solutions numériques à ses clients offre
ainsi à ses employés une belle cause
ainsi qu'une activité parascolaire aux
élèves du quartier
c'est également des quartiers avec le un
des plus hauts taux de décrochage
scolaire amoyal on est malchanceux parce
que c'est notre quatrième année puis les
jeunes ont été un plein de capacité à
chaque année à chaque année on peut
accueillir une vingtaine d'étudiants
mois çi par robben dans ça mais j'ai
quand même appris beaucoup de choses ici
que je savais pas faire
moi je suis toujours seule à l'école
sogem l'accompagné c'est peut-être ce
qui pourrait comme peut-être m'aider
plus tard peut-être m'aider
pourquoi je voudrais créer quelque chose
on si jamais c'est la seule entreprise à
avoir fait une offre du genre à l'école
saint henri au grand bonheur de cette
enseignante qui donne le cours
orientations et choix de carrière en
troisième secondaire
en fait il a seulement que je connais et
puis vraiment qui invite les élèves du
cycle art donne à manger qui les
accueillent un engagement unique qui
sera repris l'an prochain avec l'espoir
de donner à d'autres entreprises
l'idée de faire la même chose ici à
nourrice despatie radio canada montréal